this video is sponsored by EA more on it
later on in the video
[Music]
anime season is that all it takes is a
good episode or two to completely swing
things around and throw these kinds of
bliss out of whack especially with
mid-season lists like this remember
demon slayer's popularity sparked due to
a late episode and Bocce took towards
the end of the season to start storming
through the anime world but it's fun to
make these mid-season lists and see
which shows of all the momentum so
without further Ado here's my top 10
anime to watch this winter 2023 first
off is campfire cooking in another world
foreign
the year is 2023 map is still going
overdrive in taking those big projects
[Music]
you know these guys from stuff like uh
chainsaw man aot Jiu Jitsu Kaizen and
now they find themselves busy with an
isakai indeed it's not the place to
expect mapper to be but man did they do
a good job on this one isakai and
cooking as a combination is nothing new
we already have a handful of those but
campfire cooking still manages to be
quite entertaining in its own right we
all know the drill don't we amongst a
group of Heroes transported into another
world one guy who's the protagonist gets
blessed with a power that's completely
out of the left field so in this case
instead of something that can still be
combat worthy so Yoshi finds himself
specializing in
yep cooking but hey cooking so well can
still pay off big time especially if you
can use it to attract the aid of the
legendary wolf fenrir thus this story
follows the Duo's journey in This
Strange World solving problems and
preparing the best and most amazing
meals for this world's inhabitants as
you might expect campfire cooking is a
really chill anime there's the isakai to
give the whole thing a vibrant setting
in the occasional fight but it's mostly
focused on the cooking aspect it's funny
relaxing and actually it's quite
educational if I do say so myself
reborn to masterblade from hero King to
extraordinary Squire is the number nine
entry
ah yes yes yes yes the gender bender
isakai it's a genre that's picking up
steam in the online web novel
communities there's just something
alluring about being a guy reincarnated
into a girl and training from the ground
up owning your skills and unlocking op
Powers as you go along and I'd say that
as a show it's fine something that
isakai fans will really like it's paced
rather quickly but it's got enough cool
moments beautiful art flashy action
scenes and Great Character designs that
will keep you entertained I just feel
that in terms of what isakai and action
fantasy fans typically look for Reborn
to master the blade has a good enough
grasp of it the protagonist does have an
interesting Dynamic within herself
having Different World Views and
personalities between her two
incarnations still I've got to say the
show finds itself as a niche title that
I'm not sure I could just recommend to
anyone randomly so I'm placing it here
but I did definitely enjoy it enough to
include in this top 10 list
following that we have Reincarnation of
strongest Exorcist in another world
[Music]
and just like that we're back to
reincarnation land again oh [__] here we
go again I love anime on a more serious
note though I think this is The
Reincarnation show that viewers will be
more receptive towards it's more by the
book and it does create an Underdog
Story setup with our protagonists
reincarnating into someone with far less
power than he initially had to wield the
fights are pretty nice here and I've
been enjoying the character growth in
terms of the protagonist seika and the
people who we all know will end up
becoming his traveling companions
apparent because we know that it does
feel lonely at the top sometimes and
returning as a more toned down version
of himself gives seika a chance to forge
bonds that he never had the chance to
before what we know it's going to be a
power fantasy at the end of it all it's
the journey and the ride itself that's
gonna matter if you're a fan of the
genre and the whole power fantasy thing
then this is a show for winter 2023 that
you're not going to want to miss
this year
now before we continue I must ask you a
question have you heard about the
hottest game in town wild Hearts it's
our sponsor EA's new game that puts a
unique spin on the hunting genre in this
game you'll need to craft and build
using ancient technology to take on
giant nature infused beasts and save a
world that's gone wild so are you ready
for the challenge because you'll need to
use all your skills courage and cunning
to hunt down these beasts and the best
part you'll get to explore a fantasy
version of medieval Japan with multiple
Seasons each hiding their own secrets
and Beauty it's like taking a virtual
vacation to A Whole New World but that's
not all you get to choose from eight
different weapons that suit your play
Star whether you're into smashing your
foes with an imposing more or defeating
them with style and elegance with a
bladed wagasa there's plenty for every
kind of Hunter and if you're feeling
social you can hunt with up to two other
friends online which makes it even more
exciting what's cool about wild Hearts
is the way it Blends crafting building
and hunting into a unique gaming
experience you'll use Ancient technology
to build traps and weapons that will
help you take on these huge beasts so
what are you waiting for check the link
in the description and get ready to take
on the peace and become the ultimate
Hunter
next is Kubo won't let me be invisible
[Music]
people apparently do so the anime Gods
bestowed upon us a blessing mainly
because of that Kubo won't let me be
invisible ended up being one of the
shows I look forward to watching the
most this season there's just something
so appealing with the dynamic of a
socially awkward guy and very upfront
girl who likes to tease him or with a
cutesy Charming presentation and we got
the thing with Ozaki and the like but
the ones that emphasize that sweet
playful innocence just resonate with me
so much better needless to say them I
liked Kubo and it's largely to do with
the implementation of the chibi
manga-like segments that add a distinct
flavor to the show it does give the show
a unique Essence something to set it
apart from its peers no matter how
superficial it's gonna seem and as for
the plot well nothing much really needs
to be said honestly speaking it's just
something that you've watched to unwind
and get some Smiles on your faces it's a
pretty good show overall from the get-go
you know what you're going to be getting
and there's going to be loads of it so
you won't be disappointed
foreign
next up I have high card
entering the season high card is a show
that I'm excited for but I also feel
it's pretty niche in terms of
anticipation I've always liked modern
fantasy series and the idea of cards and
superpowers makes the whole thing feel
like a blend that I really would enjoy
very much and then there's the stakes
and the somber faded tone of the setting
so far I haven't been disappointed it's
pretty much met my expectations and then
some it's got the right mix of
intriguing setup some characters that
test what we know about morality and the
whole gritty Western inspired backdrop
to it if anything it kind of feels like
boom goes stray dogs as people have
noted I can't wait to see what's to come
especially with knowing about the
different powers bestowed by the cards
pan or not I'm really high on high card
I just wish we've got a steadier Pace to
get more information on the cards in the
world
at five we take a look at buddy daddies
I've had a number of Misses or
overlooked shows coming into Seasons
before and I think that's the fun of
these preseason videos it also shows
that there are still some surprises to
come several weeks into the season and
for this one buddy daddies is the one
that I'm enjoying a lot
I can't help but feel that body daddies
is a show that's Riding High on the
popularity of spy family and Yakuza
guide to babysitting but even without
that comparison buddy Daddy's remains a
pretty fun show to follow and watch
while it doesn't quite hit the mark If
you compare it to spy family buddy
Daddy's does do a better job at being
the show that brings a crude type of
humor and over-the-top action in a
similar vein to say lupon the third
buddy daddies won't be the show to set
the anime world on fire but it's
something that has let me go through the
pressures and the stresses of the weekly
grind I don't pay much attention to this
entering the season but I am sure glad I
decided to give it a shot
is a girl is next on the list
[Music]
now here's a show that I'm sure people
didn't Overlook has been one of the more
anticipated titles coming into winter
2023 and after a couple of episodes I'd
say that it definitely deserved all of
that hype domojan is an anime that's
been nothing but entertaining I can't
get enough of the antics of the main
characters when it comes to Slice of
Life titles with very simple plots like
this a lot of the owners falls on the
anime production team and the voice
actors and they've done a wonderful job
at bringing this funny and colorful tale
of teen romance to life here the cool
thing is that underneath all the fluff
and the funny there also like some good
themes that resonate with viewers like
how people can be different from what
they seem at first overall a wholesome
tale that dazzles us with comedy yet at
the end of it it's also a romantic
Journey that's worth every step of the
way
[Music]
next on my list is the Angel next door
spoils me rotten
tomato
if you've been following the channel you
might know that I'm more of an action
type of anime viewer however a genre
that I also really like is the rom-com
specifically these sweet and Charming
shows with a blend of self help in it
I've always favored snuffle and I still
rank saigano as one of my favorites in
the genre and
ah I gotta tell you it was perfect
perfect everything down to the last
minute details the angel next door
spores me rotten however tickles a
slightly different itch will a simple
act of kindness help a person reach a
better more fulfilling life and the
process experience the joys of a budding
relationship seems very idealized
doesn't it but hey it is the world of
anime and it's fun seeing these
idealized and warm relationships develop
over the course of many episodes what
helps us enjoy the ride even more is the
art and the overall production quality
of the show it's quite appealing and it
gives a soft touch that's on par with
what you'd expect from a show like this
warm and sweet are basically the key
words to describe this one it's not
something you'll get too hyped about due
to insane fights or heavy drama but it
doesn't need to be in order to entertain
oh
what
oh hold up
try gun Stampede is next on the list
being a boomer in modern anime standards
meaning a guy who's been watching stuff
in the 90s Trigun is an anime which is
really close to my heart actually it's
not anime of the decade or anything like
that but I do feel it deserves its place
as one of the classics from its time
Trigun Stampede as a return of the IP in
the modern times ended up being a little
bit more 50 50. on one hand I do like
how Trigun was reintroduced to the
modern anime fans it's still got some of
the Swagger and the cool action scenes
of the original it's really nice to see
Vash back in action and still being the
badass that he was for new people coming
into the show Trigun Stampede does its
job decently well it's got great fight
animation and the constant action Ultra
key fans always at the edge of their
seats it's not quite the original but I
feel that it's an adjusted version for
modern audiences who prefer their action
and flashy visuals it's the same though
that it'll never be mainstream because
it's completely CGI I really hope people
do give it a shot
so the rule
however if you're up for Action titles
the top Anime on this list is the one
for you it's near
now at this point in 2023 it would be
trite to say that video game adaptations
are just stepping up with a lot of
bangers now both in the world of anime
and Western animation this video game
adaptations have already stepped up and
taken the World by storm the cyberpunk
anime was great so under the same good
circumstances I had no doubt that the
near anime would be a home run and for
the most part of it it actually is it
would have been a challenge to adapt
such a widely known and popular video
game product as an anime but this
adaptation captured the magic of the
games the themes regarding Humanity the
Epic action sequences the breathtaking
aesthetic and style that fits the title
so much the air has an IP and as a
universe has so much story to tell and
are pleased to say that the amazing
narrative style has been captured in
this anime adaptation I dare say that
this can end up even better than
cyberpunk when it's all said and done I
mean that is a pretty high bar but the
near adaptation is on the right track to
be one of the best game adaptations in
the past couple of years unfortunately I
did say on the right track with a
broadcast suspension and an indefinite
return date the whole thing could very
well be derailed so knock on wood so
even with a few episodes that are out I
personally have this as my favorite
anime this season I hope the eventual
return to broadcast will continue to
build on the positive momentum the first
few episodes laid out
it is still quite early but how does
Miley stack up against yours let me know
what you think in the comments section
you can also check the channel further
for videos that you may like and don't
forget to check out wild Hearts links in
the description I'm glad to have you
here and I thank you so much again for
watching this video I'll see you next
time take care